creo que todos hemos escuchado la
palabra bacteria bacteria y normalmente
la asociamos con cosas negativas cuando
piensas en bacteria dices
estos son gérmenes entonces normalmente
asociamos a la bacteria con bueno con
gérmenes déjame ponerlo así la asociamos
con gérmenes y de hecho si son gérmenes
y pueden causar un gran número de cosas
negativas o al menos esto es el punto de
vista más común entonces qué te parece
si le haces listamos para bueno para
saber que estamos en la misma sintonía y
para asegurar que sabemos todas ellas
así que las cosas malas de las bacterias
malas de las bacterias
son las siguientes
y bueno lo primero que se me ocurre es
que causan muchas enfermedades por
ejemplo tenemos a la tuberculosis déjame
notarlo la tuberculosis exacto también
tenemos por ejemplo a la enfermedad de
la ema así que lo voy a poner aquí vamos
a escribirlo la enfermedad de lyme la
enfermedad line y bueno así puedo seguir
y seguir y aquí hay que ser muy
cuidadosos porque cuando las personas
hablan acerca de una infección está
frecuentemente es causada por una
bacteria ojo también puede ser causada
por un virus y es que una infección en
general es cualquier cosa que entra en
tu cuerpo y sea ventaja de él para poder
replicarse y del proceso hace que te
enfermes entonces déjame adaptar eso
también estamos hablando de infecciones
bacterianas de lujo y toda esta
percepción de que las bacterias son
cosas malas es lo que probablemente nos
da una buena razón de por qué casi todos
los jabones de ahora dicen en sus
empaques que son jabones antibacteriales
así que por todo esto existen jabones
antibacteriales y bueno seguramente las
personas que hacen jabones deben de
conocer este pensamiento convencional de
que las bacterias son cosas malas pero
no siempre es así y seguro ya sabes a
dónde voy con todo esto no todas las
bacterias son cosas malas hay algunas
bacterias buenas por ejemplo y déjame
escribir aquí voy a hablar de las
bacterias buenas voy a ponerle así y
bueno lo primero que se me ocurre es que
si tú pueden ser unas bacterias en la
leche éstas nos van a ayudar a producir
yogur entonces déjeme escribir lo que yo
y esto obviamente es algo bueno porque
el yogur es algo delicioso para comer y
seguro también dice ok también tengo un
buen de bacterias en mi intestino en mi
intestino las cuales me ayudan a digerir
la comida y todo eso cierto pero a lo
mejor me dirás que sigues pensando que
las bacterias son cosas malas y bueno no
quiero cambiar esa idea en ti no voy a
tomar partido en este debate ya que en
general evitó tomar partido en los
debates en estos vídeos de ciencia tal
vez en un futuro haga una lista de
vídeos de debates y tome una postura y
pero en este caso no lo voy a hacer lo
que sí es que quiero marcar que en gran
medida tú estás hecho de bacterias y no
solamente de bacterias en tu intestino o
bueno en el yogur que comes también hay
bacterias por ejemplo en la placa de tus
dientes
la placa dental que esencialmente es
causada por bacterias y es un tipo de
capa que eventualmente causa caries y no
sé qué más cosas y bueno también se me
ocurre pensar en el acné que puede
sufrir en la cara acné y en los barros
pero no solamente hay tienes bacterias
de hecho voy a darte un dato que a mí me
impresiona por cada célula por cada
célula
la del cuerpo humano del cuerpo y bueno
estoy pensando en las células que tienen
tu propio adn y bueno éstas tienen su
núcleo de su hablaré en un segundo pero
lo que quiero decirte es que por cada
célula humana tienes 20 bacterias en tu
cuerpo tienes 20 bacterias
y esto es algo sorprendente y bueno tu
respuesta puede ser ok esto está muy
bien pero estas bacterias deben de ser
mucho más pequeñas que las células
humanas entonces esto debe ser una
pequeña muy pequeña fracción de mi masa
y tiene razón no es que nuestra masa sea
en su mayoría bacterias aunque si te das
cuenta somos mayormente bacterias por la
cantidad de células que tenemos pero
incluso se quitará toda el agua del
cuerpo entonces aproximadamente el 10%
de nuestra masa serán bacterias y esto
es impresionante el 10% de tu masa
corporal es decir que si yo peso
aproximadamente 68 kilogramos bueno de
esos 68 kilogramos tengo 6 kilogramos de
bacterias paseándose conmigo a donde
quiera que voy en general siempre
pensamos que las bacterias están
solamente no sé sobre nosotros pero en
gran medida es una simbiosis
somos dos criaturas bueno no solamente
dos criaturas son los dos tipos de
criaturas que viven juntas ojo yo estoy
diciendo que en mí solamente vive en un
cierto tipo de bacterias de hecho hay
miles de tipos de bacterias que viven en
mí hay una gran diversidad y es por eso
que solamente estoy aproximando en
términos generales el número y tipos y
diversidad de bacterias que existen en
nuestro cuerpo y ojalá que con este dato
de aquí te des cuenta de que las
bacterias son súper importantes para
nuestra existencia día a día y sólo para
asegurarme de que entendimos la magnitud
de esto en un vídeo anterior y volví a
buscar esto en un vídeo anterior dije
que teníamos en el orden de 10 a 100
en billones de células billones de
células humanas ahora si lo pensamos con
la idea de que por cada célula del
cuerpo tenemos 20 bacterias estoy
hablando de que tenemos cerca de el
orden de 200 a 2 mil a 2 mil billones
billones
de bacterias base de
y yo soy un hombre muy higiénico me baño
todos los días y no por eso las podemos
eliminar de hecho aunque podríamos
eliminarlas a todas de alguna manera no
sería nada bueno que lo hiciéramos pero
bueno esto es suficiente porque estoy
segurísimo de que ahora estás diciendo
ok en este momento estoy convencido de
que las bacterias son muy importantes
pero como se ven realmente las bacterias
son estos pequeños organismos
unicelulares esta de aquí va a ser mi
bacteria la voy a poner algo así y son
distintas a las células que nos forman a
nosotros y cuando estoy hablando de
nosotros estoy incluyendo a las plantas
a los animales
y a los hongos de todos ellos voy a
hablar y la gran diferencia o al menos
la diferencia que las personas notan
primero es que todos los organismos que
pertenecen auc área es decir estos de
aquí
qué
un día que por cierto incluyen a las
plantas a los animales a los hongos y a
los protistas en todos ellos su adn se
encuentra adentro de un núcleo celular
así que este de aquí va a ser su núcleo
núcleo muy bien y bueno todo su adn está
dentro de un núcleo normalmente este adn
está en su forma de cromatina así que lo
voy a dibujar así aquí está todo su adn
en forma de cromatina algo extendido
como todo esto mientras que las
bacterias antes se preguntaban si tenían
núcleo o no y esto es porque no hay una
membrana que rodea al adn entonces lo
que tienes es sólo un montoncito de adn
más o menos se ve algo así a veces está
en forma de bucle y todo este gran
círculo en donde está su adn se llama
núcleo jde así que lo voy a notar este
sería uno
lee
núcleo y de ahora bien cuando nosotros
vemos algo y decimos mira este tiene
cierta cosa y este no de cierta manera
estamos suponiendo que una cosa es
superior a la otra o digámoslo así que
es más avanzada pero la realidad es que
las bacterias estas de aquí son las
bacterias éstas están en más ecosistemas
están en cada parte del planeta mientras
que los eucariontes no y hay mucha más
diversidad de bacterias que la que hay
en el área entonces cuando realmente
piensas en esto puedes darte cuenta de
que las bacterias son los organismos más
exitosos si un cometa fue a estrellarse
con la tierra dios no lo quiera los
organismos que probablemente
sobrevivirían serían las bacterias en
lugar de bueno los eucariontes es decir
estos organismos que casi siempre son
más grandes no siempre que tienen núcleo
y los organelos membrana osos como las
mitocondrias y todo lo demás y
hablaremos un poquito más de esto en el
futuro las bacterias por lo general son
las grandes con citoplasma y tiene en su
adn por ahí y bueno también tienen
ribosomas ya que necesitan codificar
para las proteínas al igual que nosotros
y algunas de estas proteínas servirán
para formar sus flagelos estos flagelos
que en general son colas que les sirven
para moverse déjame dibujarlos aquí y
bueno también tienen estas estructuras
llamadas pil el cual es el plural de
pelouse ok todas estos que tenemos aquí
ir aquí voy a dibujar otros más
estos peeling permiten que las bacterias
introduzcan variación genética en sus
poblaciones y aquí quiero hacer una
pequeña nota estoy diciendo que las
bacterias no tienen pared celular pero
de hecho hay otra clase que suele
clasificarse como un tipo de bacteria
las cuales se llaman arqueas así que la
voy a poner aquí estoy hablando de las
arqueas
y estoy haciendo esta nota porque quiero
hacerles un poco de justicia siempre son
como la oveja negra y es que antes
suelen llamarle ar que bacterias pero
ahora la gente se dio cuenta al ver su
adn dejan dibujar por aquí su adn se
dieron cuenta que no eran bacterias y es
que originalmente las vieron dijeron
hype estos amigos no obtienen un núcleo
membranoso por lo tanto deben de ser
algún tipo de bacteria pero ahora que
somos capaces de ver su adn podemos ver
que son muy distintas pero ambas tanto
las bacterias como las arqueas se
consideran procariotas se consideran
provocar yo antes
digo
que es esencialmente significa que no
tiene núcleo vamos a ponerlo así sí
no no
y bueno esta es la idea más común pero
de manera más general podemos decir que
no tienen todos estos organelos
membranoso que nuestras células si
tienen ahora la siguiente pregunta qué
es lo mejor que estás haciendo es bueno
cómo se reproducen estas bacterias hacen
algo no muy distinto a la mitosis así
que para eso voy a bajar la pantalla y
vamos a hablar de esta forma de
reproducción que bueno realmente no se
llama mitosis se llama fisión binaria
así que le voy a poner aquí vamos a
hablar un poco de la fisión
binaria binaria y aquí no voy a entrar
en detalles del mecanismo de cómo
funciona todo esto pero en general lo
que pasa es que tienes a esta bacteria
que tengo aquí déjame ponerla por acá
tengo por aquí a mi bacteria y esta va a
replicar su adn así que voy a poner aquí
dos veces su adn
esta idea realmente es muy sencilla voy
a duplicar su adn lo estoy poniendo por
acá y después de que duplica su adn
entonces tenemos estos dos núcleo y des
y el citoplasma se empieza a separar por
lo tanto esto se va a empezar a separar
algo así y algo más o menos así se forma
una escisión por aquí y después se
separan se separan en dos bacterias
justo esto que tenemos aquí y cada una
de ellas tiene su núcleo hoy de lo voy a
poner más o menos así y también por acá
y bueno lo impresionante es que pueden
codificar las proteínas necesarias para
formar su apéndice
extra es decir esta hello este flagelo
que tenemos por aquí que es como una
cola larga que les ayuda a moverse y
esto es fascinante porque a pequeña
escala
puedes tener este movimiento motor aún a
estas pequeñas escalas usando algo muy
primitivo aunque van a esperar creo que
la palabra primitivo no es lo adecuado
para no darle un juicio de valor pero a
lo que me refiero es que estas cosas que
son muy pequeñas tienen un ancho del
orden de nanómetros del orden de decenas
de nanómetros es decir no tenemos muchos
átomos con los cuales lidiar son capaces
de dar este movimiento en forma de onda
este movimiento en forma de onda y esto
hace que las bacterias se muevan y es
sorprendente ahora a lo mejor estás
diciendo bueno en el primer vídeo de
evolución dijiste que vemos la evolución
todos los días y las bacterias son un
ejemplo de esto dije que cuando usamos
antibióticos pensamos que nos ayudarán a
eliminar a las bacterias pero esta
bacteria puede ser que te
algún tipo de resistencia puedas
sobrevivir y entonces sea más apta y con
ello seguramente te preguntas bueno cómo
es que estas amigas bacterias obtienen
variación y bueno una manera y ésta es
una manera donde todo el mundo puede
obtener variación es a través de
mutaciones puede ser a través de
mutaciones
acciones y como las bacterias se
replican tan rápidamente se reproducen
tan rápidamente aunque se tenga una
mutación no sea una de cada 1000 veces
cuando tengas millones de bacterias
tendrás miles de mutaciones entonces
esta es una forma en la que se puede
obtener variación y también existe esta
otra forma la cual es muy interesante y
no me quiero referir a ella como
reproducción sexual porque no lo es en
esta forma de obtener variación no se
forman gametos y los gametos no se
fecunda ni formando un cigoto y todo lo
demás pero existe la posibilidad de
tener dos bacterias déjame dibujar a una
por aquí y una por aquí y voy a dibujar
a otra por aquí aquí tengo mis dos
bacterias y estas dos pueden acercarse
tanto que uno de sus pelis recuerda que
los peeling que los voy a poner justo
aquí son todos estos tubos que tenemos
de las bacterias déjame ponerlos así
aquí tengo un montón de peeling aquí
también tengo un montón
bill y algo así son pequeñas estructuras
en forma de tubo y bueno puedes tener
aquí que los pellets de dos bacterias se
junten y formen un pequeño tubo que
enlace estas dos bacterias y luego lo
que puedes tener es una mezcla de lo que
hay dentro de una bacteria y dentro de
la otra bacteria por ejemplo si déjame
dibujar por aquí su núcleo y de mí voy a
dibujar por aquí es un núcleo hoy de lo
voy a poner algo más o menos así y bueno
por aquí está también tiene su núcleo
hoy de algo más o menos así y ahora voy
a dibujar estos pedazos que se conocen
como plásmidos que son pedazos de adn
por aquí tengo un plásmido se me ocurre
poner por aquí otro plásmido este por
acá estos dos son solamente pedazos
circulares de adn y a lo mejor en este
amigo que tenemos aquí tiene otro
plástico que lo voy a poner más o menos
así este plasma y lo que esta otra
bacteria no tiene ya lo mejor este es el
plásmido r le voy a poner un nombre este
de aquí va a ser mi plásmido plásmido
el cual es conocido por hacer
resistentes a las bacterias a muchos
antibióticos y de hecho hay un mecanismo
que hace que las bacterias sepan que una
bacteria no tiene este plásmido y diga
oh este amigo no tiene el plásmido rr
por lo tanto vamos a replicarlo y le
vamos a dar una versión a este amigo del
plásmido r ojo todavía no se entiende
muy bien como pasa esto pero se puede
replicar el plásmido y pasarlo y también
puedes tener estas cosas llamadas
transposones tal vez en algún momento
algún vídeo de esto porque nosotros
también tenemos transposones y bueno
estos son partes de adn que pueden
brincar de una parte del adn a otra
parte y estos también pueden acabar en
otra bacteria entonces en este caso que
no es un tipo de reproducción sexual lo
que esencialmente tienes es que las
bacterias se conectan y estas bacterias
están constantemente intercambiando adn
entre ellas y el adn brinca de una am a
otra por lo que puedes imaginarte la
gran cantidad de combinaciones de adén
que pueden suceder incluso en lo que uno
puede llamar una especie de bacteria que
muy rápidamente se puede convertir en
múltiples especies y con ello volverse
resistentes a distintas cosas si esto
las hace resistentes a los antibióticos
entonces de cierta manera pueden
propagar la información a otras
bacterias para producir estas proteínas
que hagan resistentes a los antibióticos
oa cualquier otra cosa esta es una forma
de introducir variación va sería acción
y en este caso este tipo de forma de
introducir variación se le conoce con el
nombre de conjugación bacteriana
conjugación cuando transfieren su
información a través del virus o en su
plural peeling ahora una última cosa de
la que quiero hablar en este vídeo es
acerca de los antibióticos y para eso
voy a bajar un poco más la pantalla
porque quiero hablar de los antibióticos
y estoy seguro que tú has escuchado
mucho esa palabra
porque muchas veces cuando una persona
se enferma lo primero que hace es tomar
un antibiótico y un antibiótico no es
más que toda una clase de químicos y
compuestos algunos de ellos derivados
naturales otros gnome que matan
bacterias entonces los antibióticos
matan bacterias si alguien va a entrar a
una cirugía en lugar de preocuparse de
que les dé una infección ahora sólo les
deben de dar un antibiótico para
prevenir que las bacterias crezcan en
ellos y la pregunta aquí es cómo se
descubrieron los antibióticos o de dónde
vienen y de hecho vienen por alexander
fleming y es muy importante ese nombre
así que déjame notarlo alexander a
alexander
fleming
y te digo todo esto porque en mi opinión
el descubrimiento de los antibióticos es
el descubrimiento más importante para la
medicina por eso estoy poniendo este
nombre en estaba estudiando creo que
eran los staphylococcus o algún tipo de
bacteria no recuerdo bien lo olvidé pero
estaba estudiando una caja de petri él
estaba usando una caja de petri así que
déjame dibujarla este círculo de aquí va
a ser mi caja de petri y va algo más o
menos así y bueno en la caja había unos
nutrientes para que las bacterias
pudieran crecer así que voy a poner de
este color a las bacterias teníamos a un
montón de bacterias que estaban
creciendo en esta caja de petri y las
voy a poner más o menos así algo un poco
rápido más o menos así por aquí voy a
poner un montón de bacterias que estaban
creciendo en esta caja de petri y
entonces clement lo que hizo fue salir
del laboratorio y cuando regresó vio que
un moho
un hongo el cual era de color azul
verdoso había crecido en el centro de su
caja de petri así que lo voy a poner por
aquí aquí tengo a este hongo a este modo
y bueno él se dio cuenta que había un
espacio entre el hongo y donde estaban
las bacterias y las bacterias no podían
acercarse al hongo entonces tomó un
pedazo de este hongo para ver qué tipo
de hongo era y se dio cuenta de que este
hongo o este mou eran penicillium así
que déjame notarlo
li
sí
y se dio cuenta de que este hongo tenía
que tener algo debía de producir un
cierto químico que esencialmente mataba
las bacterias a su alrededor lo que
permite que las bacterias no se acerquen
a él y esto lo llevó al descubrimiento
de la penicilina la penicilina y este
descubrimiento sucedió aproximadamente a
finales de los años 20 un poco antes de
que estallara la segunda guerra mundial
y así a las personas que tenían heridas
de bala o que tenían que sufrir
amputaciones les dieron penicilina por
primera vez por primera vez les dieron
antibióticos los cuales les van a servir
bastante bien para matar las infecciones
bacterianas esto que nos preocupaba en
un principio y bueno ahora ya sabes que
si tienes una infección bacteriana
si tienes tuberculosis o la enfermedad
de l'ain o cualquiera el tratamiento va
a involucrar tomar antibióticos y ahora
hay muchos muchos más tipos de
antibióticos
cuáles vienen de fuentes muy diversas
pero la idea general es la misma tú
quieres matar bacterias pero no quieres
matar a todas las bacterias porque
algunas de ellas son buenas de hecho
estamos hechos de muchas bacterias
incluso no sé si lo mencioné pero acabo
de recordar que también hay bacterias en
nuestra piel que nos ayudan a quitar la
grasa e hidratar la piel y hacer nuestra
piel bonita y suave entonces puedes ver
a las bacterias como algo negativo o
puedes verlas como algo positivo o
puedes verlas como algo intermedio ni
buenas ni malas pero lo que es realmente
sorprendente al menos para mí es que
vivimos en simbiosis con ellas recuerdo
un episodio que vi de star trek déjame
enseñarte este dibujo por acá en el cual
habían personas de raza alienígena
déjame traer a uno por acá más o menos
así teníamos a unas personas que eran de
una raza alienígena que tenían una forma
humanoide algo así pero resultó que
tenían un pequeño gusano en su tallo
cerebral así que lo voy a dibujar por
aquí tenía
un gusano o un [ __ ] o algo en su tallo
cerebral justo por aquí lo cual hacía
que empezaran a controlar el cerebro de
las personas y estas personas empezaban
a actuar raro y esto parece un concepto
alienígena muy raro no como si
tuviéramos aquí un extraterrestre extra
terrestre
3 afectándonos de una cierta manera pero
si realmente piensas en esto nosotros
estamos igual y no solamente con un
insecto sino con el orden de millones
cientos de billones de bichos están con
nosotros día a día y estoy hablando de
las bacterias las cuales nos hacen ser a
nosotros nosotros yo estoy aquí grabando
este vídeo o quizás debería decir que
las bacterias están grabando este vídeo
lo que sí es que es bien sabido que las
bacterias pueden afectar nuestro estado
mental actualmente hay un gran número de
investigaciones que indican que cierto
tipo de bacterias pueden causar
esquizofrenia
de hecho la sífilis la causa y bueno las
bacterias también pueden causar
depresión y se sabe que en fases
avanzadas de la enfermedad de l'ain para
eso dejamos subir un poco esta pantalla
en fases avanzadas de la enfermedad de
l'ain se puede afectar la condición
mental de las personas que tienen la
infección entonces
además de que afectan cada parte de
quiénes somos a lo que me refiero es que
es muy difícil hablar o pensar en el ser
humano sin el 10% de nuestra masa de
bacterias o pensar al ser humano sin
estos 200 a 2000 millones de bacterias
que hacen que nosotros seamos nosotros